we have some breaking news for you here
at Sky News and Sarah Ferguson The
Duchess of York has recently been
diagnosed with breast cancer and
undergone an operation we have a
statement here from a spokesman for The
Duchess it says Sarah Duchess of York
was recently diagnosed with an early
form of breast cancer detected at a
routine mammogram screening she had
advised she needed to undergo surgery
which was taken place successfully The
Duchess is receiving the best medical
care and her doctors have told her that
the prognosis is good she is now
recuperating with family The Duchess
wants to express her immense gratitude
to all medical staff who've supported
her in recent days she's also hugely
thankful to the staff involved in the
mammogram which identified her illness
which was otherwise symptom-free and
believes her experience underlines the
importance of regular screening so Sarah
Ferguson Dutch of York diagnosed with an
early form of breast cancer has had an
operation which has successfully taken
place
um you are watching Sky News we'll
update you as and when we get any more
on this if you're just tuning in Sarah
Ferguson has been diagnosed with an
early form of breast cancer it was
detected in a routine mammogram and she
says that that of course underlines the
importance of regular screening we're
going to take a break now stay tuned to
Sky News